i think that most tech reviewers are
being way too nice to this phone
saying things like it works pretty well
or
you can't go wrong with this phone and i
think that's false
now before you pixel lovers download
this video please hear me out
i think a few of these reasons are going
to be really surprising to you
and i think that some of you guys should
just wait another year or buy a pixel 4
8 instead now i partially understand why
tech viewers are being nice to this
phone
the pixel 5 is the hardest phone i've
ever had to review
there's a part of me that really likes
it but there's also a few glaring
hardware issues
that will be a disappointment to both
previous pixel owners and those coming
from
samsung oneplus and iphone i absolutely
have to be honest and cover these
downsides so that you can make an
informed decision and i think unless you
want a couple specific features
you're gonna be better off with the
pixel 4a or 485g
while saving money at the same time or
possibly an s20
fe or just keeping your current phone
for another year
let's start with the best things about
it as usual the software is
fantastic it is by far my favorite
version from any android
as it should be it's the base one and
i've rarely had any animation glitches
or any issues like i sometimes have
with skinned versions i do miss the face
unlock from the pixel 4 but it's a
worthy trade-off to get rid of the top
bezel
and the rear fingerprint sensor works
fantastic
and these things are really great to
have in 2020
still i do wish that they allowed us to
have face unlock using the front-facing
camera
next the battery life is awesome which
is such a relief
after the pixel 4 xl you're gonna get
about eight hours of screen on time
which is
great this is due to three things a
battery that's ten percent larger
despite the phone and display being
smaller the screen resolution
being lower two and a half million
pixels compared to 4.3
which is a big difference but no i
didn't miss the extra resolution on the
six inch screen
and lastly a much slower processor which
needs
a lot less power this part is very
important but i'll cover this in just a
bit
let's start with the exterior changes
when i first got this thing in my hand
it felt like the back was made out of
pressed cardstock
it's definitely unique but i still can't
decide if i like it or not
we have aluminum underneath with cutouts
for wireless charging so it's strong
but one thing is for sure the resin
covered side and back
doesn't feel anywhere near as premium as
the previous pixels
and barely feels nicer than the 350
dollar pixel
4a the camera bump also looks cheapish
but as a plus
it barely sticks out the adaptive 90hz
1080p display
looks great and unlike last year i never
noticed when it dipped to 60 hertz
the front cutout is larger than i'm used
to which is weird because google said
they made the front lens narrower to
keep the cut out small
but it's still bigger than samsung's
while the camera
isn't as wide angle the display itself
is brighter than older pixels but it's
still not great compared to the
competition
it maxes out at 670 nits and only if you
use auto brightness
the iphone 12 s20 fe and oneplus 8t are
all
closer to 1200 nits and they're also
brighter in your normal modes as well
this means that the pixel 5 won't be as
easy to see in bright sun
and hdr video won't look as good this is
also where my biggest
issue and disappointment with the pixel
5 comes in
and it's something that most older pixel
owners won't be expecting the pixel 5
has the worst
speakers i've heard in years when i
turned on my first youtube video i
thought i had a defective phone
it is that bad and i'm not joking or
exaggerating
take a listen for yourself
[Music]
the pixel 5 sounds worse than the 350
pixel 4a and the 400 iphone se
which is still using the same speakers
from 2017.
this is shameful because in 2017
google's pixel 2's
front-facing speakers sounded incredible
and
absolutely killed iphones and samsung's
and now
they sound like junk this is because
there is no actual earpiece speaker
but the phone's display is being
vibrated to make sound
now phone call quality is okay not as
good as older pixels but not bad
but when listening to music and watching
videos the sound is
very unbalanced and the sound coming
from the front has no bass at all
let me know if this matters to you down
in the comment section below
for me this is huge and if you have a
pixel 3 or older
this will be a massive downgrade i'm
guessing that google did this to make
the bezels
slightly slimmer than the 4a's but in a
world where the competition has been
perfecting stereo sound
i would much rather have the four ace
bezels
with their better speakers now let's get
to the processors where i have good news
and bad news and no
the bad news isn't that the processor is
slower than the pixel 3's
which it is the real bad news that i
wasn't expecting
was how slow 5g was in my real world
testing compared to samsung
and the iphone the pixel 5 really
disappointed now your mileage may vary
based on your carrier and your city
but i'll give you my experience i'm
using t-mobile and we only have sub 6 in
my city so the pixel shouldn't have any
issues
and it does connect to 5g right away but
the speeds are barely any better than my
iphone which doesn't have 5g
and the lte is already pretty slow i
tested data speeds in the morning and
evening
in three spots around town in my first
test the pixel 5 got 47 mb per second
download and 23 upload connected to sub
65g
i then tested my iphone and it was
barely slower for download
and almost twice as fast for upload
connected to 4g
which was weird my next test was deep in
the valley during peak times
where my signal is worse and where i'm
routinely disappointed in my iphone's
lte
and it got 15 megabit per second
download and 20
upload the pixel 5's 5g connection was
just slightly better
at 21 download and 27 upload i
immediately popped my sim into the note
20 and it got a download speed of 73
megabits per second and 25 uploads i
don't know what's going
on i have the unlocked us pixel 5
sent to me by google so there shouldn't
be any issues
but my speeds are nowhere near the 5g
samsungs
maybe they have better modems with their
high end snapdragons or maybe it's
because the antennas are hidden behind
the aluminum and resin back
or who knows this made me very curious
how the pixel 5's 5g compared to the non
5g version
of the 4a testing them at the same time
and place
the 5g was slightly faster in download
speeds but slightly slower in upload if
you're wanting to upgrade specifically
four 5g connections either with the
pixel 5 or the 4a 5g which have the same
chipset
i would make sure to do some
side-by-side tests to make sure that
you're getting what you're paying for
speaking of processors yes this one is
weak performance is much worse than the
pixel 4s and actually matches up fairly
closely
to the pixel 3 in terms of cpu but the
pixel 5
actually gets smoked by the pixel 3 in
terms of graphics
let me put this simply if you're a gamer
this isn't the phone for you
i don't remember the last time we tested
a brand new phone in this price
range that actually had noticeable drop
frames while
gaming and keep in mind most people keep
their phones for three years now
which is what google is promising for
software updates in terms of ui
smoothness i didn't notice any issues
but it also didn't have any issues with
the 4a
i tested both in geekbench and
surprisingly the 4a pretty much
matched up the iphone sc absolutely
smokes it with its a13
and of course the iphone 12 will be even
faster and that will last a solid five
years what i did notice in terms of
performance is longer load times for
larger apps and games
and longer photo processing times than
the pixel 4
which makes sense because we have a
slower cpu and no more
dedicated neural core this doesn't mean
that the photos are any worse
in fact they are basically identical to
the pixel 4 other than a few new
software editions
panoramas still look bad because of
crazy compression but hdr performance is
still
very good now let's get into photo and
video quality and i'm going to go deep
here and give you some info and
perspective
that most reviewers aren't google is
using the same exact sensor as in the
pixel 3
which is a four year old sensor now and
they say it's because their algorithms
work
best with it which is true the s20 ultra
had
lots of issues when it came out with
that 108 megapixel sensor
but after six months of algorithm
optimizations
the note 20 images are amazing there's a
reason samsung and apple keep upgrading
their sensors every year
despite needing software tweaks that's
because there are so many improvements
every year
sure in optimal conditions the pixel has
great hdr and night shots
but the competition has caught up there
and because of the newer sensors
readout speed and noise performance is
so much better and i can prove it using
google's own pixel 5.
here's a sunset photo taken with the
main camera and it looks good
but then i zoomed out to 0.9 so the
pixel changed to the ultra wide
yes it's not as sharp because it's
cropping in almost two times into the
ultrawide
but check out the extra dynamic range
they're getting from this new sensor
and this is without three years of
optimization so this sensor
will keep getting better the use of this
older sensor is most noticeable in
faster action shots and medium lighting
which most tech reviewers don't show the
noise performance and readout speed is
worse than the competition
and shots my iphone would have captured
result in blurry images with the pixel
the same thing is noticeable for
portrait shots in medium lighting where
the processing is focused on blurring
look how much noise and artifacts are in
elon's face
and then compare it to the note 20 which
is also digitally cropped in to match
of course the note 20 is way more
expensive so we'll be doing an
unbiased blind camera comparison against
the s20 fan edition
and the iphone 12 next week so make sure
you subscribe if you want to see that
it's still a bummer that google forces
you to use a crop for the portrait mode
when everybody
else stopped doing this limitation so
you can actually get wide portraits
we also no longer have the telephoto
lens last year the pixel 4
zoom shots smoked the iphone 11 pro but
this year they look
much worse and of course you can't even
compare them to a high-end samsung
the result is even worse if you compare
4k
video quality against the iphone 11 pro
which actually looks decent compared to
a waxy compressed mess
on the pixel with that said since google
only wanted to have two lenses
the ultrawide is more useful and even
though the field of view is narrower
than all the competition it looks good
in optimal conditions like high contrast
it looks really good matching the iphone
on samsung
but interestingly there's consistently
less contrast
which is weird for google i'm guessing
this will be fixed with updates
it also looks great in night mode shots
where google's algorithms are fantastic
but just like the main sensor in scenes
where google can't do its magic
like medium lighting the new ultrawide
falls behind
because of its smaller sensor my guess
is that google is using these sensors
because they're cheaper
especially if you're buying in bulk and
they're the same sensors that are used
in the 4a
and the 4a5g so other than the 4a not
having the ultrawide
the image quality is the same google
software is fantastic pulling out so
much dynamic range from shots
and doing a great job at night mode i
just wonder how much better these images
could be
if they use new sensors at this point
the competition has caught up or even
beaten the pixel
and in areas like night mode where you
might see the pixel excel
you don't get the whole truth when
looking at camera comparisons
in this shot the pixel captures an image
i couldn't even see with my
eyes and when comparing to the note 10
and iphone 11 it looks better
but what you can't see is that the pixel
took 10 seconds to capture this image
and another five seconds to process it
the note 20 took five seconds and the
iphone took
only three seconds and they showed him
right away when i manually set the
iphone to the same 10 second exposure
it captures an image with less noise and
with more detail due to its much newer
and larger sensor
lastly let's finish off with video where
there have been some major
upgrades we finally have 4k 60 on the
main sensor which is great
but the front facing is still 1080p and
even the ultrawide can only do
1080p even though it has more than
enough pixels
i'm guessing there's not enough
processing power to oversample
and cropping would no longer make it an
ultrawide
audio quality has been improved and
thanks to killer algorithms and heavy
crop
stabilization is really good if you
shoot a lot of videos this would be a
good reason to upgrade because google is
finally taking video more seriously
overall the pixel 5 isn't a bad phone
other than the speakers those are
definitely bad
the software experience is fantastic the
display has been improved in some ways
over the older ones
and the battery life and ram performance
is great but once again i think google
overpriced their high-end phone if this
thing came in at 599
it would be much more compelling and the
older camera sensors and the worse cpu
performance and graphics
compared to other phones like the fe the
oneplus the iphone 12
would just make sense at that price and
once this phone drops down
to that price point it will be a better
buy
but to be honest unless you need a 90hz
display
or the ultrawide pick up a pixel 4a
instead for 350 bucks you get six gigs
of ram the same 128 gigs of storage the
same main
and selfie cameras almost identical
displays both
1080p oleds with similar brightness the
battery life is also great and you get
better speakers and a headphone jack
if you really need or want 5g grab the
4a5g
as long as you know that there's an
actual difference compared to lte and
your city
and for those of you guys that still
want great cpu and graphics performance
like the older pixels had
you might want to go with the oneplus or
a samsung fe
for a similar price let me know your
thoughts down below and if you want to
see how the pixel 5's photos
and video compare to the fe and the
iphone 12 make sure to subscribe and
enable those notifications
thank you guys for watching this has
been max and i will see you in the next
[Music]
video